if i want to make face app basically
what i'd do
just draw some eyes on a white board and
like see where it applies to detail
[Music]
so i've seen my instagram feed just
blowing up with pictures of old people
turns out it was all my friends just
using face app
we made a video about face app like a
year ago and the results were pretty
hilarious
i've actually been doing a ton of work
with ai face manipulation particularly
our deep fake videos now i think the
technology underneath the program is
actually pretty similar i want to see
what happens when we apply it to our
panels
we're going to take pictures of people
that we have from both being young and
old and we're going to compare to see
how accurate it is but i also want to
figure out how it works so we're going
to try to uncover that mystery for you
today is this kind of awkward that i'm
wearing this suit
you mean we're buddies
out on a retirement cruise in the same
beard
they even got the neck rolls yeah
it's me dude
oh my god dude they do the hand too ew
it looks like a freaking camel spider
bite it was the war the war got me the
great war of 2030. all right jake this
is exactly the same damn son yeah he's a
guy named bob bob watson he's like a
roof shingler he lets himself inside
your kitchen to get like a coors light
from the food bob stop drinking on the
job again bob nick are you just
insinuating that i'm just gonna be an
old drunk
look at this
twice old jean carter dude jimmy carter
got him
got him
it's like super super accurate like here
ren put your hand up next to your face
it's doing your wrist wrinkles correctly
and your fingers correctly what is this
giggle party over here oh
my god i'm gonna see if it works on a
pano okay
dude that's like an attack on titan do
you know i know
are you guys ready for stage four though
four levels deep man oh no
oh no oh
dude dude it's a titan the neck
one let's dh let's dh
[Laughter]
the way like it's kind of patterning the
wrinkles
it kind of has that feeling like it's
basically just learned little patterns
from other images and it's kind of
recognizing where those patterns would
fit in on this image i'm
suspicious that this is actually using
machine learning and basically the same
thing that we're doing with deep fakes i
say 100 this is absolutely machine
learning it's not just aging up the face
it's like it's actually adding hair
where necessary adding like neck
wrinkles down here and like you're
saying it's even adding wrinkles to the
skin and the arms and various other
aspects pretty much anything that looks
youthful it's changing let's do a quick
accuracy test here
here we go
wow
that's pretty good it looks i mean
exactly like ian mckellen honestly let
me take a picture of a young celebrity
and i'll show you the old version and
you tell me who the celebrity is okay so
step away for a second juice is right
here nico if you need a young celebrity
oh
all right don't look don't look
wow
it's pretty obvious jake who's this
celebrity uh
it's robert de niro obviously
christian you don't know who i took a
picture of when they're young but tell
me who is this
i'm morgan freeman yeah obviously
if you told me the younger one it might
have been more confusing slightly more
challenging
who is this
oh it's the king's dude the kingsman
colin firth that's his name
yep
it's becoming really apparent that
everyone kind of ages the same way we
all have like skin that starts sagging
in the same spots we all have wrinkles
that form in the same spots i really
want to see a video with this and i
think the way to do that is basically
just take the video render it out as an
image sequence import all those images
into your phone then you have to
manually go through and do it i really
wonder how it's going to change between
each frame there's no continuity between
before and after i'm really curious to
see how it goes over time
tomorrow
what am i about to see
i'm an old man
that actually looks pretty good the
wrinkles stay really consistent on my
face
the beard's a little all over the place
so yeah this is really impressive they
could probably make it temporarily
consistent you know what i bet
that that is one year away i bet you
within one year i see faceup for video
61.4 percent of our watch time is from
people who aren't subscribed only 34 of
the people so if you're not subscribed
please consider doing so it helps out
the videos helps up the channel
subscribe subscribe
think we can nail down exactly what it's
doing you know we could also try is a
fake face like just draw some eyes on a
white board and like see where it
applies to detail so we need to do is we
need to recognize how is it applying
these wrinkles how is it learning this
texture and applying it and i think we
can kind of pinpoint some patterns i
think we can nail down exactly what it's
doing oh is it gonna see that there's a
face there oh it did it did
oh what's it gonna do
so it seems like it's working so let's
hold it i guess make that face old
it just added wrinkles to the white
board but that's like a perfect wrinkle
like test right there i got to see what
uh if you're putting a beard on it oh my
god this is what the stock with them
this was some hairstyles
he looks like a member of bts some kpop
dude can we add hair then screencap that
then add more stuff and see if we can
create a full face from that drawing
hairstyle he's giving some bangs
let's give it some glasses applause okay
what about a nice little beard nice
little beard needs some sort of beard
it's good to have your beard apply okay
what the let's make it old there we go
wow and then i'm going to re-import
that okay so little by little it's
actually shading it um like it's
actually filling in like skin colors it
created those cheekbones from scratch
that's pretty amazing
from that to that that actually looks
like you know those little artist
renderings after someone robs a bank
pretty amazing that it can take a
whiteboard sketch that you just drew and
actually make human facial features from
it so this is definitely doing some sort
of like pattern recognition you can kind
of see kind of see the patterns being
repeated
so if you're like me you're probably
wondering how this face app program
works now if you've been following this
channel for the past few weeks at all
you've probably seen the deep fakes that
we've been working on deep fakes are
basically a type of machine learning
where you are passing an image into the
computer it's running that through its
ai and learning on that image and then
giving you an ai generated result that
has been informed by the things that i
learned on you also may have seen style
transfer style transfer is really cool
style transfer basically determines
which parts your image are just textures
and styles and what do you need to be
able to understand what that image is
style transfer will basically break
those two things apart preserve the
structure of your final image but apply
the style for a different image onto
that so you can make every picture look
like van gogh is starry night that's
basically what you're getting with face
app
it's really weird but what i saw was
just wrinkles everywhere but it's like
there's a pattern to it the way this
program is working is basically a mix of
style transfer with some other
structural cues kind of like how a deep
fake works if i want to make face apps
basically what i'd do is i'd first
program in a facial landmarks
recognition system eyes are here the
nose is here the mouth is here and then
i would train the computer on here's
what various sets of wrinkles look like
next to the eyes next to the nose next
to the mouth and then the computer can
be fed a new face with new landmarks and
then go okay there should be wrinkles
here wrinkles here wrinkles there a
mustache here a beard there so i did a
little experiment to see if i could kind
of replicate this effect on a very base
level so i gave it this picture of a
wrinkly old woman so took the style from
this picture now it's just a picture i
took a picture of myself and i applied
that picture of the wrinkly woman as the
style on my face and the wrinkles are
there the structure is actually there
now the background has wrinkles too it's
all just become wrinkles
so if you were to then inform this with
some facial landmarks kind of end up
with what face app is doing it's doing a
style transfer of the wrinkles it's
learned from looking at hundreds of
images of old people
and it's doing a style transfer onto
your skin you can combine a style
transfer with recognizable landmarks you
can end up creating something like face
app you know i'm almost wondering if
there's like a little bit of image
generation i think it's called pix2pix
let's see who basically has input for
example this purse and it kind of takes
all the pieces of purses and puts them
together so that might actually be
what's going on i guess i can just
literally i'm gonna draw you dean
oh wait this is for cats
i don't i have no idea what's gonna
happen i think it's gonna turn you into
one of the characters from the new movie
cats
either way this overall technology is
definitely what's being utilized the
crazy thing here is we are generating
imagery in a different way than we used
to do it so when it came to cgi computer
generated imagery you'd sit there and
build a 3d model and try to make it look
real but now we're getting to the point
where
it's horrifying
okay i can draw cats i guess there are
thousands if not millions of pictures of
cars muzzle flashes phones whatever it
is that you want it all exists online so
you can kind of just be like hey
computer you've seen a million pictures
of what a phone looks like you just draw
me a new phone and it does you kind of
tell a computer to piece it together
from its knowledge of what things look
like computer just does it for you and
that's just going to get better so yeah
i'm super excited for ai i think there's
so many cool things that are going to
happen so we're going to hit a point
here it's often referred to as a
singularity
oh that poor creature help me
anyways you get the idea it's ai
whatever it's crazy things are going to
change very fast yo nico nico nico real
quick i just want to do one thing for my
boy my idol my hero yeah bruce lee all
right let's see let's see what our boy
bruce lee looks like if you were alive
today
nothing happened whoa
nothing happened
it doesn't it doesn't work on bruce lee
he's fro he's perfectly frozen in time